it's difficult man this mindful thing is
very hard hi I'm Ashley and I am a woman
on the verge of a nervous breakdown I
need a reality check a wake up call a
spiritual awakening whatever just
something to help me find some peace hey
guys I'm Jude for the next two weeks
I'll be practicing mindfulness I really
don't know what it entails or what to
expect but if I was to take a wild guess
I would say that mindfulness is being
centered like mind body and soul I think
it's gonna be a lot of meditating out of
like reconsidering how I'm gonna be
spending my time and what that means for
myself and others and overall being like
a calms and human being which I'm not
I'm really excited to see what these
next two weeks have in store for me and
how I come out on all this side see how
it goes it's day 1 of a new way of life
and I'm ready let's get this party
started guys we're meeting with John
Divisie today who I hear is a
mindfulness master he's a certified life
coach
he gives inspirational talks around the
world he hosts workshops on spirituality
and mindfulness and we get to talk to
him today about what we have signed up
for in this challenge mindfulness is
that lovely intersection between being
aware of what you're focusing on in
other words where your attention is
going in addition to what your intention
is so how you're feeling about something
or how you want to feel about something
so if our thoughts are kind of dictating
the perception of our reality then we
need to really understand what it is
that we're thinking about in order to
understand why our world looks the way
it looks what would you say is some pre
lewd information or tips you would give
me go in and see the next two weeks
having the awareness of knowing when
you're distracted is one of the biggest
keys to achieving a greater sense of
mindfulness and reminding ourselves okay
what am i focusing on right now how am I
feeling right now they're gonna be
legitimate times where you just need to
lay on the couch and zone out and watch
Netflix and that's totally cool but in
those moments in your life where you
know you
to be there a mindfulness practice
allows you to spend a little bit more
time present so you could really
understand what's going on in your life
what you have to be grateful for in your
life and what the good stuff is that's
really going on to just enjoy your life
more do you have any I guess advice for
us as we deal with stress in the next
two weeks so if we can really stop and
take a breath deep enough to kind of
feel it move through your entire body
you're instantly gonna feel a little bit
more relaxed go with the flow something
works for you great if something doesn't
great and feel free to reach out to me
at any point if you guys have any
questions I'm here for you he helped me
realize a lot of things mindfulness does
not mean that you keep your mind silent
it means that you're aware of the
thoughts that you're having and why
you're having them and the intention
behind your thoughts which is something
I don't do it all we have so much that
we can really learn from him not just
tips and techniques but also just find
the energy he exudes and how contagious
that is I suddenly became aware that
like though my breathing is really
shallow and I'm feeling really stressed
and some of my muscles are tensed up
right now and immediately when that
happened I like started breathing deeper
and kind of like relax my muscles I'm
hoping that I can get into a good habit
and continue to be a better person
so my train today decided to be 45
minutes late and so now I am too and I
so very badly me today because we are
going meditating thank God
just to breathe and relax and de-stress
something that I have not been doing all
morning
[Music]
Oh
hi yeah welcome to mindful for the three
of us who've never experienced
meditation before or if done it
successfully what are some tips yeah to
relax and enjoy it one we want the mind
to be really relaxed and flexible
spacious on the other hand we want to
encourage the mind to be really clear
and bright and alert so because that's
what we're trying to do in our minds
that's how we try to hold our bodies and
you can have your hands just resting on
your thighs the idea being that there's
some intentionality oh no I'm gonna
meditate often in the Buddhist
traditions the eyes are half open with
the gaze loosely down at the ground to
say three to five feet in front of you
you can also experiment with closing the
eyes but sometimes we lose that
brightness Center
[Music]
begin by taking a deep breath in
along
[Music]
really inhabit the moment your body the
space
lift your gaze or open your eyes
whenever you're ready
I am shocked that now like relaxed and
they feel like it was like a hard reset
for me which is what I was looking for
you how do you feel right now is how I
want to feel at some point every day I
don't know how I've been living 25 years
ago meditating we're gonna get myself
this time to just breathe it out are you
meditating without me for a decent
duration of that I was able to achieve
that balance of like alertness and
clarity but also relaxation
I'm really starting to notice myself
snapping into like mindfulness I just
came home from one of the most genuinely
productive days and had in a long time I
was on a date the other night it was
kind of like an intuitive reminders like
practice active listening and like
connecting with the person and not like
focused on my noodles or whatever if
today was a testament of what
mindfulness can do I am so on board
oh no it's been it's been really
difficult to be mindful I'm not gonna
front I want to know better ways to deal
with the situation's around you and how
to actively use mindfulness to help you
in those moments are in those situations
going through it guys and going through
it I'm like I don't like to take breaks
and I'm gonna try to do it John
recommend an ID and a breathe just
breathe breathe 45 seconds my desk is
all the way over there I don't have my
computer with me no laptop no anything
I'm really good this is definitely
something I'm gonna try to incorporate
into my everyday life ain't no stopping
me now a little anything hit better
taped it I'm gonna take I have this
negative self-talk devil on the shoulder
that is telling me you're wasting your
time doing this the world is turning
outside and you're sitting here in your
room and the angel my shoulder is kindly
telling him no no no she'll be the best
version of herself to take on what the
world has to offer I think that's
probably the key to this whole thing is
the two of them being copacetic
then again said hey some not-so-great
news today I had that wake up moment of
like okay well what are you focused on
and a car you processing those emotions
I have a feeling it's gonna stick with
me in a lot of ways beyond what this
challenge is asking of me you go through
your days feeling better about things
it's a hard lifestyle change but I think
it's a great lifestyle change I think
it's worth the commitment it's worth the
extra thought especially in is in delt
life you know I've heard the term
mindful eating and be thrown around a
time as a big buzzword and I've
understood the gist of it but I've never
applied it to my life I eat when I'm
stressed when I'm bored I ain't needed
to change my relationship with food so
today I'm gonna
much far away from my desk focus on the
food in front of me and how that is
going to fuel me to do what I need to do
today so I meant eating at home has been
a bit of a struggle
having Meghan at mindful guide us so
beautifully was really special it's just
not the same experience at home by
myself in silence so I did a little bit
of research and came across an app
called headspace and it's for at-home
guided meditations well oh my god that
felt so good
just for a little bit longer yes
well yeah I think the world can wait
just a few more minutes
today I'll be using the hex based app
that actually put us on to feeling
overwhelmed I think that'd be a good one
to try I'm gonna start off with three
minutes baby steps here speaking by
taking a big deep breath breathing in
through the nose noticing how the body
expands as it fills with air and as you
breathe out through the mouth
just gently using the eyes oh my god I
feel so much more relaxed you're just
doing that like just mellowed me out
so our decor and put things in
perspective and meditation feels I
really exhausted I am going to try this
meditation from headspace start to relax
your body and let go of the day while
easing into a restful night's sleep well
it's not nighttime as you can see it's
actually a five o'clock in the afternoon
but I know I gotta get some more sleep
let's get right into it
I'm time and I'm exhausted
[Music]
I'm just gonna turn off his camera
sensors cameras gone good night guys
[Music]
I was on the subway and someone made a
rude comment to me which normally would
have like kind of pissed me off I just
decided to practice a little a little
empathy with the mindfulness and just
realize maybe this person is just having
a rough day we've all been there it was
kind of practice for me like not taking
something personally or letting an
external factor affect my well-being and
my mindfulness it might be hard to
remember what we went through and to get
ourselves back to this state of mind and
so I just bought a couple of like
self-help meditation mindfulness books
I'm gonna be reading the power of now I
just gave Jade actually a headspace book
and Matt's gonna be reading 10% happier
hopefully these books will be a resource
for us to keep on it because this is
good stuff I made it I made it through
14 days of mindfulness I feel way more
in touch with myself I feel way more at
peace if I've got better coping
mechanisms now moving forward to deal
with stress in my life I cannot tell you
any spiritual truth that deep within you
don't already know all I can do is
remind you of what you have forgotten I
am just getting started man I am so
appreciative of mindfulness I'm
definitely not taking it for granted
I think mindfulness is something that
everyone should definitely practice or
at least try hey it will hurt it's kind
of led to an overall better improved
quality of life and I feel like a better
improved version of me going forward
that's pretty nice
[Music]
[Music]
you